hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast early disease detection
performing NMR understanding how a
better analysis of metabolites in serum
and urine can help presented by
Professor Claudia lukina and professor
Elaine Holmes today's presentation will
be moderated by manfred Sproule i'm
christie jewel elaborates and i'll be
producing today's event today's
educational web seminars brought to you
by lab roots and sponsored by Brooker
Brooker enables scientists to make
breakthrough discoveries and develop new
applications that improve the quality of
human life
Rooker's high performance scientific
instruments and high-value analytical
and diagnostic solutions enable
scientists to explore life and materials
and molecular cellular and microscopic
levels for more information please visit
bruger calm before we begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation we
will additionally answer them offline
after the webinar if you have trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
lastly near the end of the presentation
a poll will pop up on your screen which
we kindly ask you to complete your
answers and suggestions will help
improve our webinar program and is
greatly appreciated it is now time to
enter the topic of the day
Manfred over to you
Thank You Christy for this nice
introduction and thank you everyone for
joining us today our webinar titled
early disease detection performing NMR
understanding how a better analysis
metabolites in serum and urine can help
is actually presented now or by cloud
you looking at and Elaine Holmes who has
a cloud you looking at is a full
professor at chemistry the University of
Florence he is a co-founder and director
of firm the center of magnetic resonance
and the Cir MMP in the university
consortium and magnetic resonance of
metalloproteins his research interests
include development of NMR by structural
methodologies locked one and nuclear
relaxation animal paramedic species
relax imagery bioinorganic chemistry and
what we are talking about today
metabolomics professor Elaine Holmes is
professor of chemical biology and the
head of the division of computational
and systems medicine at Imperial College
with over 20 years of experience in
metabolic research now first of all I
would like to give a short introduction
to show the basis where this research
actually is done on and this is on our
IV dr platform that is used in many of
these metabolomics research labs
you talking about a platform and the
concept overall I've EDR stands for in
vitro diagnostic research it is a
completely standardized full fully
automated concept using this six hundred
megahertz platform with predefined
hardware and also embedded solutions for
clinical and translational research the
big advantage of this concept and the
platform is that we can integrate of
results from different users all over
the world in of course that creates a
large big data pool that can be used for
much better statistical analysis and
using data from all over the world and
this is due to the very very good that
would usability of NMR and also the
transferability of animal so also of
course having such a large data pool
from different sources it can help to
really speed up the translation into
future diagnostic methods and that could
be either for personalized medicine
which is a very important topic these
days as well as for big studies on
population bases to look for example
into phenotypes and associated risk
factors and here I want to shortly
introduce this platform and the enabling
tools
so here you can see now the instruments
or the platform in the middle this is a
600 megabytes on a 600 megahertz magnet
which actually has a very good shielding
so that means there is no danger outside
of the magnet for any magnetic
disturbances that would be there and
what we are working on I start on the
top this is for example food omics we
have several important collaborations we
are working with the phenome centers you
probably be aware of the international
phenom center network that has been
brought to life about one and a half
years ago and this now include centers
which are located in Europe like in
London in Birmingham and in Singapore
also in Australia in Paris and of course
there are quite a few groups to join
these international films and the
network and using the standardization
that NMR will write here they can
actually exchange all their data
we also very gonna bio Bank QC program
that has just been released which allows
actually to check the quality of
specimens which are in the bio bank but
at the same time to generate spectra and
also analytical data like quantification
on the spectra that can be stored into
the bio bank but we also talk to
clinical service providers hospitals and
medical practices this is more for the
future but also work on forensic
departments environment and human health
is an important aspect here and of
course we also have applications for
pharma industry just to mention toxicity
screening those response optimization
and of course to look into metabolite ID
that means the metabolites form from
trucks in the body
now the concept is the following
you see here the base is this dedicated
platform at 600 megahertz this is under
ISO 9001 and ISO 13485 on top of that we
have what we call our IV diem methods
the SOPs which describe how to collect
samples
how to store samples how to prepare
samples how to measure samples and also
standardized analytical procedure to
follow in addition there is a spectral
compound a reference spectral base of
compounds occurring in body fluids
mainly that has 800 compounds in there
with more than 20 3,500 spectra I
included and also there is a forum for
the users of this instrument platform to
exchange information with us and of
course between other users on top of
that we have the layer which we call the
enabling tools and so the the ones which
are available in the moment is a
lipoproteins up class analysis we have
plasma serum quantification of small
molecules that has just been released
we have a neonate during quantification
with 150 compounds which are quantified
under full automation we also have child
adult urine quantification also 150
compounds and also released already is
the bio Bank quality control - on top of
that we have our R&D ecosystem there
actually customers of ours or
collaboration partner force hours that
are using this platform and the SOPs
they are trial work in development of
diagnostic routines which then of course
can be put onto this platform and made
available to other users
you see here an iPad because this is the
concept that we are following we have a
fixed hardware platform and we have a
fixed interface definition how
applications are actually talking to
this whole system and therefore of
course we have here really the same
concept
to be able to actually have multiple
solutions on on an instrument to make
sure that this instrument can work very
efficiently so what does that mean you
can see here for example this is a
little bit an analogy to the internet so
in the internet of course there are
protocols which has to be kept otherwise
google amazon now all they are called
they could not work and on the same
thing like the Internet Protocol we have
our SOPs which make sure that users can
exchange data between themselves but
also with broker for example for they
mode analysis now starting a little bit
in an explanation what are the enabling
tools so if we look for example on the
SOPs for serum and plasma when that is
used then we can deliver the
quantification of for example here B I
Eliza this is our lipoprotein subclass
and the quantification of small
molecules we have made sure that this
can run on the fast experiment that only
takes about eight minutes give us
lipoprotein information these are about
115 parameters and also 26 more molecule
quantifications from exactly one same
experiment and then of course there is
also an extended version which has some
additional experiments which allows us
to do even more sophisticated
quantification and analysis and then we
have the bio Bank QC tool which works
also unknown the SOPs that we are using
here for the other analysis
now when we look into quantification on
small molecules of this is important in
epidemiology a lot of health problems
cardiovascular disease diabetes cancer
then of course we can have information
about personalized profile in plasma and
serum and identifying metabolites which
are relevant in there we can also look
the food-related changes in plasma serum
composition to show the influence and
health and of course it allows us for
example to monitor and optimize
treatment now I just show you a report
this is the small molecule
quantification so you can see here the
components and you can see that we have
a large variety of chemical classes that
I actually analyzed with one single
experiment which conventionally might
take actually more than one or two
methods and you also see here when we
look into this gray bar that this is a
normal concentration that we get from
our reference cohorts and the black bar
this is actually the person itself so
you always know if that person is within
the reference range from our models or
not so it's explained a little bit
better here you see here in create this
is a 95 percent range and a model set
and then the actual person which in this
case here really is inside the range if
you look down here you can see for
example here we look at pyruvic acid
which is clearly outside of this normal
model range that we have identified from
a large number of compounds so the
quantification actually is quite complex
but you don't have to care about that
because this is all done in automation
so you can see how these signals
identify as you can see here for example
creatine or creatinine which are
somewhat overlapping but the program
takes care of this without having any
problems
now for example when we look into TMAO
dimethylamine oxide of course this is a
relevant now metabolite also when we
look into cardiovascular health and here
we see for example how you can look from
two different angles to the same disease
and we have the angle of the small
molecules as you can see it here and we
have the angle actually of the
lipoproteins which of course also play a
large role like when we look into food
especially food and health high blood
pressure fatty liver disease then of
course inflammatory cancer
cardiovascular and several others so how
does that look what you see here now
this is a report again looks quite
similar to the small molecule report you
have seen so we have this gray bar
determining the normal ranges in our
model and then you have the actual
person which is identified with the
black bar and as I mentioned before
there are main parameters these are the
main class and the overall triglyceride
cholesterol and then we go into the main
class is LDL cholesterol HDL cholesterol
April April April to an April B we have
particle numbers I will not go into
detail on all of that I just want to
show you a comparison when we look into
a control sample and a donor which
actually had a cardiovascular event
three days after the blood collection so
if we look here on the control sample
side you can see that all of the sub
fractions whether it's triglyceride or
cholesterol free cholesterol and
phospholipids the person is in the
reference range if we look on the right
side you can see that there are
substantial deviations from the
reference range and what is also
important for example when we look into
the LDL you can see in the LDL main
fraction the person here
in actually quite in the middle of the
distribution and our reference cohort
but if you look to the individual
subclasses you can see that this
distribution actually is quite unhealthy
because we have the health actually is
improving when we have here a high
concentration on the first three LDL one
two three and the low concentration on
LDL four to six and here it's vice-versa
but if you just take your doctor's main
panel that you would get from your house
doctor he would not recognize that there
is a problem NMR can do that within a
few minutes but we have of course done
very relevant now study is a ring test
to see how transferable these results
are so you see here a comparison of the
results on a nice under example four
eleven instruments at five different
sites and you can see the R value here
of the correlation between different
instruments and the average is extremely
good and the last I want to talk about
this is the quantification in urine
which of course also supports for
example epidemiology but also health
problems like in diabetes metabolic
syndrome kidney and cancer and of course
also again personalized profile monitor
and optimized treatment and look into
food-related changes so here I only show
a small fraction of it because we have
here of course one hundred and fifty
metabolites in the end and you see the
same principle you see the ones which
have been identified for each of those
the dean iso spiking has been done but
we also have a special version of what
we call electronic or numerical spiking
to further identify correct Elodie's you
see the 95 percent range that we have in
our model dataset and you see absolute
and relative concentrations relative to
creatinine
then last thing is biobanks of course
here extensive quality control is very
important to sort out a loquats with low
quality or at least to mark them that
there is an issue and of course then the
QC process is actually done in quite a
few minutes like five minutes
and then the spectrum actually can be
recorded and transferred into the
biobank and then also the analytical
data as I showed you quantification in
urine plasma serum actually can be done
so I think that is what I actually
wanted to present so now actually I
asked the two professors to begin the
presentation and we start this process I
would you looking at cloudy oh please
start your presentation okay thank you
mouths shut
I thought I should say Who I am so you
already said that and I may actually
like to show that the place where I'm
working this is the magnetic resonance
center of the University of Florence and
you see the numbers are they instruments
the values animal instruments with their
frequency megahertz or field and the
ones that are circled that the ones that
I use for metabolomics in particular one
of the two 600 megahertz is an IBD our
system and so we are standardized in the
sense that Manfred was telling a few
minutes ago and my idea was to give you
a very quick overview of the approach
that we had to make a below mix and
speaking about health metabolomics
although we also look at food and well
this is let's say one of the two or
three concept slides that I have
basically this is the whole let's say
flow of information and strategy to
obtain metabolomic data and you see that
there are several ways to do that I'll
concentrate on untargeted analysis and
again I like that and as you know
untargeted analysis can be done by just
looking at the spectra and
fingerprinting the spectra by beaming or
looking at quantifiable metabolites and
so this is called profiling we have been
doing mostly fingerprinting and I'll I
think I'll take this opportunity to tell
you what we think about the virus
approaches and then move to multivariate
analysis and then we often use
supervised methods to for instance
discriminate healthy people from disease
people and this is the opening opening
the way to actually being able to
provide early diagnosis of several
diseases so this is just a few flesh
examples of what we have done and this
is all serum I'll concentrate on serum
today where we have actually looked at
disease and controlled people this is
standard statistical approaches like
multivariate analysis this is pls for
instance and you see that people with
the severe disease are clearly
discriminated from people who are
controls what I'll see what was rather
interesting when we published that
several years ago now was that when
these people were put on a gluten-free
diet which is what you usually expect
the doctor would prescribe for celiac
people you see that the red dots become
green and they move to the right so they
move in the field of the healthy
controls this is a little surprising
because as you may know they get disease
causes intestinal damage and intestinal
damage may not always be reversible but
if it is taken on time it can be
partially reversible so this tells you
that indeed there is a kind of
normalization of functions when people
have put on a gluten-free diet again
this is banned by fingerprinting so it's
just taking the spectra beaming the
spectra and looking at the various bins
or buckets to use them as variables for
statistical analysis even more
interesting is that we looked at the
potential celiac people and potential
failure people are people who have the
antibodies typical of celiac disease but
don't have intestinal damage so this P
for we thought at the beginning that
they would be normal because they the
way of functioning of their intestine is
normal but on the contrary most of them
were in the field of celiac disease
people which to us was very important
because it signaled that indeed the
metabolic profile can actually help
diagnosing celiac disease before people
even think of having the problem which
usually manifests as a kind of reactions
to to to food and so on and then it may
take time not all people are recognized
as yet immediately so this may have
strong potential implications likewise
we this was a conflict study of which we
did on his more part which was the
colorectal cancer we looked at people
with the metastatic colorectal cancer
after federline treatment so people in a
very bad shape unfortunately and here
the accuracy of recognition of disease
people versus as the subject is hundred
percent because it's really the disease
is well advanced and in the end
ultimately all of these people died by
metastases but work was interesting and
was somehow rewarding also for the
physicians with whom we were
collaborating was that among these
people who died between couple of months
and a couple of years we could actually
tell or predict the lifespan by
metabolomics by looking at again this
was certain profiles analyzed by
fingerprinting and you see that you can
tell short survival people from long
survival people we even have the ratio
of three point three which is remarkable
because there is no other indicator here
that is as accurate or as strong as what
we're seeing by metabolomics so in the
end this could have actually helped
planning palliative care and is somehow
or improve the quality of life of these
people even if the disease could not be
healed breast cancer is a series of
paper that we have published over the
years where we first identify the
fingerprint this is again
fingerprinting by marketing the
fingerprint of breast cancer against the
normal people but we also could see a
clear fingerprint of metastases against
the breast cancer without metastases and
then we thought it might use this
fingerprint of metastases to try and see
whether we would be able to predict
recurrence or predict relapse or
whatever on women that at the time of
surgery had no sign of metastases but
then after a few years they would
develop metastasis and what very
interesting to see that we had the
prediction over 80% and this is
remarkable because all of this women
would have been treated more or less in
the same way we could actually provide
an additional hint to the physician on
whether or how strong should the
chemotherapy be depending on this type
of metabolic indicator of chances of
getting the relapse and this study was
later validated on a larger cohort which
was very true genius from different
hospitals from the Philippines and
Vietnam and the Bangladesh and a couple
of countries in Africa and the
prediction was slightly lower but still
still remarkable accuracy 73 percent
which was somehow telling us that
predictor is robust enough to be further
tested on larger cohorts and perhaps
even adopted as an additional tool in
cleanings as I said accuracy is lower
but not that bad
the last example is heart failure
metabolomics on which again by simple
fingerprinting of serum we could tell
easily people affected by heart failure
versus normal people but the interesting
thing here was that these people were
actually undistinguishable in terms of
stage of the disease from very very
early to very severe there was no way to
discriminate so it looked like there is
a fingerprint of our failure which is
independent of the seriousness of the
disease independent of the evolution of
the disease and which might actually be
present even before symptoms and we
checked that and this is not published
but we checked that on a cohort of about
700 plus and modern 700 blood donors on
which we looked for the fingerprint of
our failure we found plenty of them with
a fingerprint and a matching of interval
failure we were able to get hold of
eleven of these people and asked them to
undergo a a heart ACOG Rafi and out of
this eleven people six had altered
parameters that would indicate a
beginning of a failure so we think and
this is not published because the
numbers are too small but we think that
that is indeed the possibility that
fingerprinting could become a way to
early diagnosis or at least to address
these people to more specific tests now
this is the same slide as before and now
I would like to move to profiling
because this is totally different and we
are actually I have to confess that we
start to do in profiling not long ago
and thanks to blue heron
thanks to IBD our and so I would like to
show you some considerations about
profiling versus fingerprinting and this
is my last concept slide where at least
this is the way we see I mean if you do
fingerprinting and if you do it well all
the information that is present in a
mass spectrum is collected somehow by
fingerprinting even if you don't know
where it comes from even if you don't
know that the identity of the
metabolites that cause one fingerprint
to be different from another
but the statistical discriminating power
is the highest whereas profiling of
course depends if you use the
metabolites that you get from profiling
as a tool to discriminate groups then
you need to have many missable now this
goes up to a thousand but it doesn't
need to be so high but you need many
metabolites in order to get
asymptotically to the same amount of
information that is containing naturally
contained in
so our first question was why profiling
since we seem to be actually rather
successful with fingerprinting alone and
there are many reasons one is portable
you see because if you do fingerprinting
you're linked to a specific instrument
to a specific very strict SOPs that to
use thanks to broker we are with many
other labs we have standardized in the
way you have to add spectra and so on
but this precludes for instance
comparison with fingerprints taken a
different animal feeds or even with
other techniques like mass spec the
other point of course is biological
insight because then when you know what
are the masalas that constitute your
profile or fingerprint if you want made
by profile of metabolites then you can
learn about the biology the biology
physiology and biology pathology and so
on so that is invaluable because you can
learn something about the disease and
finally profiling is less prone to
artifacts than fingerprinting if you
have a stranger stab a stranger
preserve the fee for instance in vials
and so on you may miss the presence of
that by just not looking at the spectrum
but doing fingerprinting whereas if you
look at metabolites one by one and one
if I metabolites one by one this cannot
happen so this is a great advantage now
you have seen this from my friend so I
don't need to go through it we have seen
that this report is very detailed and it
is detailed this is for lipoproteins and
also you have seen that there is a very
detailed report for small metabolites
small molecules and we have a few
examples that are all in progress all
very preliminary and nothing is
published so I cannot even give you some
actual details but we have actually
started using this this IVD are from
blue-headed this predictor and this is a
discrimination between epitaxy from
Mecca that is B this was not dictated by
diagnosis but just by the curiosity
scientific curiosity to see whether this
could be discriminated and also
discriminated from LT subject and the
result is the
if you look at the first panel on the
left this is what you get from the 34
metabolites that have been identified in
cell Michael said that this was not
identified by the Booker software
because this was before but still it's
it's a very similar thing and you see
that the predictive accuracy among the
different groups so the parity SEPA that
is B and as the subject is not so high a
68% whereas if you go to the lower right
you see the predictive accuracy by
meaning by our standard fingerprint
method it's seventy eight point two
which is significantly better then what
is very interesting for us now in this
webinar is that if you use the lipids of
fractions which is 114 different
variables you see that the
discrimination is almost as good or
practically identical to what we get
from being which means to us that with
what we are capturing from the no
suspect is probably mostly they brought
signals to the lipid component and which
are clearly identified and of course
with all the extra information that you
get from having identified them you had
from Manfred that if you can tell the
values sub fractions of LDL you can have
a much more accurate diagnosis much more
accurate risk factor and so on so of
course for equal or almost equal
accuracy then of course profiling is
much better than fingerprinting alone
and then this is a study that was a big
European study of which we got the few
samples as a side project I'd project
here in Florence and we were looking at
women with breast cancer and the
collection was very large so we were
given only hundred ninety two patients
who had breast cancer because the idea
was to see whether there was a
difference between women with high
mammographic density which is known to
be a risk factor for breast cancer and
low mammographic density so this was a
very challenging project fuser and i
think is still challenging because maybe
there isn't any difference so we looked
and the best discrimination is given by
diffusion spectra so this is still done
by fingerprinting and the discrimination
is very good 52% and if we look at
belies again so the the lipid components
we see that at least the triglycerides
are significantly higher in low density
so the density is lower risk and if
anything this study will suggest that we
should give a close eye on triglyceride
on women with low density breast because
that could be a risk factor that is not
so important for high density women so
this is more detailed you see all the
fractions and you see that this to be
LDL 1 and IDL are actually significantly
different from the women with high
density finally this is this was a
project on nutrition which is still
growing there is going to close shortly
it's European project where we looked at
people with diet at risk people at risk
of poverty and whether the diet of
people at risk of poverty would be
different significantly if that would
have an impact on health I can tell you
that the impact is not great and
sometimes people at risk or poverty it
well then through healthy people so but
it was interesting to see that again
we had the significant difference with
triglycerides and again we did the be
Liza and most of the triglycerides were
significant some barely significant some
more significant and that was seem to be
a what a
a very clear way of discriminating these
these groups so the discrimination I
should have said before it's before that
in the diet and after the diet so this
was the diet which was the same for
everyone so as I said this is a side
result of the project that was aimed at
identifying risk factors in people at
risk of poverty a last project last that
I would like to present today is a study
on colon cancer and high in low
recurrence risk and again this is
interesting just to show that again
compared the accuracy that we get from
fingerprinting with the accuracy that
you get from profiling so not
considering go there to information that
we get from profiling we have an
accuracy by the 25 metabolite quantified
by Luther addr and accuracy of 80
percent which is significant very
significant of course we have a higher
accuracy in the fingerprinting but this
is obvious because of course you have
more information here but we are getting
close so this speaks somehow in favor of
continuing the effort of identifying and
quantifying more and more metabolites to
get closer asymptotically closer to the
amount of information that is containing
fingerprinting with all the extra
benefits of course and here you can tell
which are they significant and this is
very significantly log 2 of - poor so 3
hydroxy butyric acid and acetone and
this was significant to identify high
risk and low risk and but it's it's not
irrelevant what we gather and this is
still starting progress lipids are also
informative not as informative as
diffusion spectra see that there is a
parallel behavior diffusion spectra
sensitive to large molecules and if it's
of course are usually get blood signals
so this it makes a lot of sense so again
I think this the biological conclusions
I can not give you now because this is a
very beginning of the study but it's
from our point encouraging that we are
if we look at the right stuff we are not
losing much of information and we are
getting a lot in terms of this is
zooming on all the differences again
triglyceride seems to be important and I
think I was close here and this is the
group of people who work on miscible
omics instead there is also people who
work on food that I am NOT being
speaking about but the idea of
quantifying as many as possible miscible
lights and other components I think it's
a winning idea and with this I thank you
for your attention
Thank You Claudia for this really
comprehensive review on what your work
is actually relating to so I would now
like to switch to Elaine homes Elaine
please the stage is yours now thank you
Marcus ah okay so I'm based in Imperial
College in London and a lot of our NMR
facility is part of what we have formed
into the National phenome Center and
this has really set up to do high
throughput screening of biiss fluids and
mainly in the clinical arena we also
have a patient or more personalized
medicine approach which is part of a
clinical Phelan Center and together they
rely on enema and mass spectrometry but
very heavily on NMR spectroscopy so what
we really look at in our laboratory is
phenolic and by phenome what I mean is
an integrated set of measurable clinical
and physical variables and we couple
this information to chemical metabolic
and physiological properties that define
different biological subclasses and
individuality and we're looking this at
this in the context of health and
disease and we also know that the gut
bacteria not just a human but the
bacteria the viruses all the other
microorganisms within us also have
metabolic
processes and we can also capture these
by spectroscopy so the idea as you have
learned from Manfred and Claudio is very
much that we measure biological samples
we thing to print them and then we
perform some sort of modeling on them to
look for either diagnostic or prognostic
information about different diseases and
we can take the biomarkers and model
them using various tools but the part
we're focusing on today is the
spectroscopy so why do we use NMR
spectroscopy every spectroscopic
platform has its own strengths and
weaknesses but we are essentially coming
from an NMR perspective err
although we do use a lot of mass
spectrometry now most of the founders
and our laboratory started off as an a
mass spectroscopy because it's such a
robust platform and delivers is 3v the
only technique that delivers information
on atom scented properties cloudier very
nicely describe the difference between
untargeted and targeted profiling and
when we consider targeted profile and
targeted profiling there's always going
to be a little bit of internal buret or
variation but having said that NMR
spectroscopy has repeatedly been shown
to be reproducible and robust in a high
throughput mode so you really can use it
and share your data between laboratories
so that's another attractive feature
then amar now if we're thinking of
targeted whereby we model animal data in
a quantitative fashion then the results
between laboratories which I'll show you
a little bit of more about later in the
talk it's really strongly reproducible
and it allows that together the
intelligent coverage approaches a lab of
hypothesis testing and hypothesis
generation in the same experiment we
also use NMR as a first line screen to
detect any outliers samples before
progressing on to other analytical
platforms so even if we're going to
carry out both NMR and mass spec
then what we would do is first run the
samples through NMR just to make sure
that the sample isn't an outlier and by
doing this you cut down on samples that
would really contain high lipids or high
proteins and would damage our spec home
so we use it as an entity in its own
right to to deliver scientific
information but we also use it as a
first line screening tool and that is
very important to us because enables us
to get through tens of thousands of
samples a year so we have three NMR
spectrometers dedicated the National
Freedom Center and if we consider a
relatively easy throughput of 96 sample
assays per day per instrument which
isn't full capacity but it is an
approximation to what we're currently
running we would end up running on the
three spectrometers 288 samples a day or
over a hundred thousand samples per year
and these samples across the three
spectrometers are near on identical that
the three spectrometers gives Neron
identical results so sample workflow is
very important
they've been various publications from
various gruesomeness but we basically
follow a broker's protocol and the whole
philosophies it is described in articles
by donors how but you take your sample
you do some sort of sample manipulation
and storage when you're ready to run the
sample you then prepare the sample and
it's very important that the preparation
methods are done following a very strict
for a sop or protocol so that you can
get the same results across laboratories
then you have the analysis itself or
which again there are protocols and
procedures prescribed and the following
step is to do pattern recognition or
quantification of metabolites and come
up with some sort of biological
hypothesis so all we're aiming at or
anything to do in the better metabolic
profiling community is to achieve
harmonization and whilst this is very
difficult
for NMR we've almost got there so
just reiterating we need to ensure SOPs
Nana mystical pipelines are consistent
and we do this by sharing of SOPs and
protocols and ring trials one of which
months would touched on briefly I'll
come back to but also sharing of data
bases so if we follow these very very
well prescribed protocol what we end up
with is data that we can share and per
rare diseases for example this is
important because we can share
information on on samples real
biological samples and whilst who may
not have enough in our own centers we're
looking at we can share with other
centers and get a critical mass to
various diseases that may otherwise not
be modeled adequately so the ibuprofen
ring test was a test that we undertook
between ourselves as a national Phenom
Center the Phenom Center in Birmingham
and Brooker so we had a three it we have
three different physical located centers
and in them we have five different
institutions because we include the
clinical genome center and the research
laboratory so within those five
institutions we have 11 different NMR
spectrometers and we measure two daily
quality control samples for six days of
analysis two against two replicates of
NIST samples and then we look at 40
different donor samples from real
patients now for a lot of the work we do
for cardiovascular disease for cancers
and just for everyday physiological
variation that lipoproteins are very
important
so using Brooker's bi Leifer method we
can generate data accurate data
quantitative data on 105 lipoprotein
particles and 24 small molecules and the
next slide that I was showing here just
shows you on the top panel see that the
lighter proteins are calculated May
me from two regions of the NMR spectrum
which involves a complex the convolution
of those heat shapes but from those we
manage to get accurate comes
decomposition and values and the
lipoproteins at the same time we measure
the 24 small molecules and you can see
from the bottom two spectra below these
are the standards that these molecules
are overlapped they're complex and yet
we've shown that the by using the method
Brooker has have developed we can get
good reproducible information so in
order to develop this method the
reference cohorts were the samples were
collected and ultracentrifuge iation was
done to assign the lipoprotein profiles
and we compared this with those required
in the NMR laboratory and Brooker
conducted quantification using an
electronic signal in the spectrum to
calculate the Consular proton
concentrations
just looking at linear regression
between the VI life so method in the
clinical measurements you can see
whether it's a total cholesterol HDL
cholesterol or the April I proteins that
we have very high correlation between
the NMR method versus the conventional
clinical method
the entrance in constitution represented
reproducibility of light between
concentrations was extremely high as you
can see in this site in this slide and
if we divide that down and have a closer
look across the 11 spectrometers for the
triglycerides cholesterol the April a
one and A or B and the LDL and HDL you
can see across those eleven
spectrometers the standard deviation is
given in 2008 deviation is given in
light green 1/2 times standard deviation
given in dark green you can see they're
very very tight highly reproducible so
for us this is an amazing result and if
you do in depth analysis of one sample
across the 11 spectrometers they're all
superimposed on each other color coded
the little diamonds are color coded
according to machine and institution you
can see the largely totally superimposed
and for some for some some parameters is
a tiny bit of variation but for if you
take a single sample noon analyzing
across 11 institutions you get high
reproducibility for every single one of
those 105 lipoprotein parameters the
same holds more or less for the low
molecular weight molecules and showing 6
here 6 of the common common molecules of
interest because of the conditions so
amino acids creatinine lactate branch
chain amino acids and now I'd like to
finish by showing you a couple of
applications so one of the things we all
we do here is to look at pregnancy and
complications of pregnancy and before we
look at complications of pregnancy you
should look at normal pregnancy and
across a the total gestation period for
for hundreds of women collected samples
and we run the profiles using using
standard NMR spectroscopy so these are
just the profiles it's not the
quantitative metabolites here but you
can see that between the first
second and third trimester colored in
blue yellow and gray you can see you can
separation the separation between the
trimester so as a woman goes through
pregnancy unsurprisingly her plasma
composition changes so since lipid
metabolism showed the largest gestation
associated variation rather than the
small small molecules here what we did
was to do an additional either protein
subtraction distribution analysis amuse
the dialyzer platform to do that so we
looked at 105 lipoprotein subtractions
if you perform univariate analysis on
this then ninety five of those
lipoprotein fractions are different or
shift in metabolism during a healthy and
complicated pregnancy journey and this
isn't surprising because we know that
lipid metabolism is altered in pregnancy
and I think Ruth Leigh has shown that in
mice if you take third trimester urine
and Transplant it into other mice then
they germ-free mice then they've
developed color stasis so every woman is
in a mild state of color status during
pregnancy however you can narrow this
down and get a pattern of more
predictive lipoprotein profiles and here
we resort to using 38 of the top 95 out
of the know the top 38 of the 95
significantly changing life of protein
subtractions and what this enabled us to
do was to build a quantitative
diagnostic for lipoprotein changes
during pregnancy and you can see further
from the ROC curve here that the area
under the curve is 0.94 so very high
predictive coverage of gestational age
so we use this model of healthy
pregnancy to be able to to look the
difference between healthy and healthy
pregnancy and those women who went on to
deliver preterm and the tool are in the
bottom right panel there you can see two
lines in blue the the trimester for the
term babies and
read pretend you can see by using the
healthy pregnancy model you can see the
lipoproteins for the pre turns are
totally different
now switching to urine and we're looking
at exactly the same concept so how does
quantitation of urine help us Brooker
have a nice fitting method for
quantitative fitting method for urine
because the Brooker method is not
published as it's obviously proprietary
we wanted to test it out against their
own method so we used your impulsive one
of our postdocs developed a method of
curve fitting to quantify various
parameters various metabolites and we
compare it with the Brooker now the
broker method I have to say will be much
more accurate because there could years
of work into this wave this is we're
comparing it with a an in-house method
that was developed over just a couple of
months but what we found was that if you
look at the creatinine concentrations
then there are really aren't that many
outliers and the two methods agree
beautifully so we looked at this across
seven and a half thousand samples
seventy five thousand individuals and
find incredibly high reproducibility so
knowing that creatinine is fitting well
we then move to look at other
metabolites and I think we're looking in
total of about two hundred metabolites
for those that overlap with Brooker
which was forty eight we found good
correlation mainly lower than five
percent with a couple a couple of
metabolites that were outside that range
possibly possibly to do with relaxation
and and the methods we using
don't quite accommodate in imperial for
the for for the overlap of peak but what
we find is again good correspondence
between two methods so one thing that's
missing in the literature is a really
comprehensive
validation of physiological variation
here you see gender differentiation this
is based on 6,000 individuals and you
can see from these 48 and actually only
showing 17 here but of the top 17
differential
Metabo
right you can see strongest
differentiation between males and
females we can look at the distributions
here we can look at the same for age and
then we can start to stratify these
metabolites by age and gender so you can
see for lactic acid in females over age
the lactic acid drops and concentration
in the urine where's the males you don't
really see this effect so we have
different patterns here associated with
age and gender so the first time we've
been able to establish a really
comprehensive set of reference ranges
for physiological variants looking at a
wide range of populations and you see
different behavior patterns for
different metabolites so alanine is only
a weak effect with age and gender
where's that other metabolite has
dimethylamine you see both an age and a
gender effect so what we've done is to
really comprehensively classify
distributions of metabolites over age
and we're using these now for our
pathology studies so we now know what
physiological variance looks like and we
can translate this into our disease
based studies so to summarize what I
hope I've shown you is that the Acuras
quantification of lipoproteins an small
molecule from plasma and serum is
possible using the BI lie so fitting
method these qualified metabolites can
be used to form biomarker panels the
prediction of physiological and
pathological States and is highly suited
to how to put profiling clinicians we
found don't like profiling data because
they don't understand so what they want
is a set of quantification or quantified
metabolite values and this is what we
can now deliver to them I showed you a
couple of examples one and healthy
pregnancy showing you the vast change in
life of proteins and how we can use this
to model healthy pregnancy and to
predict and healthy pregnancy or adverse
outcomes in pregnancy
similarly for urine it's consistent the
Brooker quantification is consistent
with other Peaks fitting methods and
we've now ascertained a range its
metabolites
concentrations which we're now using and
employing in various disease based
studies the finally I'd just like to
acknowledge through the lab members who
have either produced help me produced
the slide all worked on the
quantification algorithms with us and
our clinicians for providing the
pregnancy study data so thank you for
listening I'll hand back over to Manfred
Thank You Elaine very informative
presentation also thank you again to be
out you now I am talk to the audience if
you have a question we have received
quite a few questions already that you
want to ask then please do so now you
can click on the answer a question box
which is located on the far left of your
screen we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for the ones
we can't answer we will actually then
answer by email later after the webinar
is finished so I want to get started
with the questions so I start questions
for the lady first align I have a
question now what is the parents between
untargeted and targeted analysis in your
laboratory so when we started out with
100% untargeted analysis and personally
as a scientist I would always prefer
untargeted analysis to start with
because it allows you to do true
exploration and find molecules or
biomarkers that you're not that you
don't know about so it gives you the
exploratory capacity however as I kind
of alluded to our clinicians really
weren't so happy with the profiles
because they weren't equipped to be able
to look at the profiles themselves and
what they really want is an easy answer
you know which biomarkers can you give
us metabolites that are diagnostic for a
particular disease concentrated disease
condition and what concentrations are
those metabolites in so
now we find that there's a big demand
from our clinicians to have annotated
data so I think this is increasingly
becoming more and more important I would
say 50% of our studies now we do full
annotation on
Thank You Elaine so then the next
question actually goes now to include
you looking at question is is there in
the epic study is there an explanation
for the increase in triglycerides and
also since also the small molecules
available now is there also an effect of
the diet that could be studied on the
small molecules yeah so the first part
of the question is that no we don't have
an explanation for that but we seem to
observe that women that got cancer with
low density they were having more higher
values of triglycerides which might mean
that and this is not related to diet I
mean this is an intrinsic thing that
discriminate it's not not under percent
but anyway discriminates the women with
low density as if they let's say the
composition of the lipid composition was
more important for them than for those
with high density as I said this was a
kind of very very small side thing
within the big epic project and we are
still working on that so these are the
first data that we got
and they our collaboration in Florence
was kind of excited that seeing that
this was the first evidence of a
difference that they could
besides the density test so from here we
could try to go and look at what you
were mentioned the effect of diet on
that of course small metabolites would
be also meaningful and we had already
started looking at them let's say by
hand before starting using your program
so you had to do it again with your
program and hopefully also to identify
more than 20 metabolites I mean this is
already good numbers but I think what to
learn from this what we are learning
is that the higher the number of
metabolites the closer we get to the
full panel and that would be equivalent
to fingerprinting and I think as the
line was mentioning I think it's it's a
matter of culture also from the medical
community that they should start
realizing that the panel of metabolites
is a marker not just one a bolide but
the panel can be collectively considered
America okay Thank You Claudio no bexco
Alain in question about the pre
analytics how important is it to stick
to the protocols for sample collection
and preparation this is absolutely
essential I'll start by saying that
again NMR is a little more forgiving
than mass spec however if you want to
get good qualification then we've found
that really you know you need to follow
this prescribe protocols and some
selection in particular is very
important how quickly you store the
serum how long anything is left on the
bench there's all impact from the
profile if you have if you have the same
samples that you distribute across sites
it it works fine and largely you come
correct for Center effects but it's much
better not to have to do that now there
are instances for example it's better to
collect 24-hour urine samples but this
is usually highly impractical in a
clinical setting and you end up
collecting first urine first morning
urine or often even not that maybe it's
spotty runs throughout the day so there
has to be a little given taking the
system to accommodate the practicalities
of the current clinical practice but
where possible is absolutely the sample
collection should be followed and the
protocol is absolutely essential
absolutely essential to follow them
cause thoroughly
thank you back to gaudium next question
how important is the standardization in
NMR for your research how does this
compare to other analytical methods you
are using okay I'm happy to answer this
question I think it's it's vital if you
don't standardize you will never get
anything meaningful but as it was
already pointed out both by you and by
Elaine and Mark is a powerful tool
because if everything else is done
properly from the pre analytic procedure
to the analytic procedure to the
preparation of the sample for animal
itself and the way the spectra acquired
anomalies probably the best technique in
terms of quantification reproducibility
and so on and support I mean we have we
don't have such a great experience with
other analytical methods but I know
enough to say that the usually
analytical method that allows even the
good ones have a larger uncertainty then
what you would get from quantitation and
my signals if it is done properly and if
the sample is to that property
I think the bottleneck is the absolute
reproducibility in the preparation of
samples yep thank you
now I also got a question actually to my
part and the question is why is there a
difference in quantification between
newborns and all the children and adults
well the reason for that is that in the
early days of life actually the ionic
matrix which the urine represents is
quite different from the matrix that you
have and actually children are aging
turning into adults and of course this
difference in the ionic matrix will be
sold for example that actually
influences the chemical shift of the
metabolites in the NMR spectrum the
means that position of the metabolites
and the NMR spectrum and in order to
have the best sensitivity and
specificity in this identification and
quantification of metabolites we
actually have separated those
and this leads to actually lower LEDs as
if we would go over the whole range and
of course then also much higher
certainty in identification and
quantification so okay I think there is
just time for one more question and I
put that to Elaine how do you see these
quantification tools impacting on
clinical practice I think now the age of
precision medicine and also biobank and
high-throughput screening has put it in
a very good position the technology and
tools we have here will really serve the
clinicians well because we can do
simultaneous measurements on numerous
metabolites I think I think now is the
perfect time to marry metabolic
profiling with real clinical practice so
I think it's perfect timing and the
impact on permissions to be able to
process all this extra information to
move toward better disease risk markers
and better better methods of precision
and personalized medicine it's it's so
important and we're right there now okay
Thank You Ellen Thank You Claude Jung
this was really informative information
that you have presented and
unfortunately we couldn't actually
answer all questions and we are still
receiving questions so as I mentioned
before these questions will be answered
by email and now I think I give the ball
back to bristly to finalize the webinar
Thank You Manfred now before we go I
would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration additionally a short exit
poll will pop up on your screen your
feedback is important to us and we thank
you for participating we would like to
thank professor leukemic and professor
Holmes for their time today and for
their important research we would also
like to thank lab roots
Manfred sprawl and our sponsor Brooker
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through February 2019
labyrinth will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now we hope to
see you again soon goodbye